so it really i mean for as much as it
affected me
much for much more beyond that it's
affected everyone in our household
oh so it's almost like you know you go
probably through a process and
in a sense i mean this is extreme it's
probably not a good analogy i'm not full
of great analogies but if someone passes
away you go through all these stages
right you go through
or any kind of loss you go through you
know the grief the anger the
all these things there's probably in a
sense like this happened to dad
we're going through this it's the trauma
of it all and then real you know dealing
with it all these stages
that they have to go through as well i
assume absolutely in fact i think it
affected my daughter nor probably more
than affected lily
she's just a little more sensitive so i
think she absorbed it a little more
so one point we set was when i sat them
down we're all still trying to grasp
what that all happened
the thing like with the brain injury you
don't know what you don't know until you
kind of presents itself like for me
because
it was a right side injury it affects
different things it affects the left
side right hemisphere
injury will affect the left side of your
body there's other
subtle things go with it like attention
like i couldn't look somebody in the eye
like it just took me forever like
look at somebody in the outside i'd get
distracted go off it really bothered my
youngest daughter that i couldn't that i
didn't look on that when i talked to her
that's something i really had to work on
and
once i was made aware of it with through
my cognitive therapist
how long did the something like that
take it was um
ongoing for months i would say until
find that would get a little better and
she would sort of make a note oh dad's
getting better he's living in the i know
as we would so anyway allison my
beautiful wife and
and i set the girls down like okay look
this happened
obviously and it sucks so we got to
figure out what what
the message is here i said the best i
can sort of do is i think the lesson
here is
bad things happen in life but it's
how you respond to them that define you
so part of my recovery my drive to get
better was always about
i got to get better for these girls i
got to keep working for them and get
back to
try and get back to something i mean
about a week before i had my stroke
lily and i were hiking up and running
canyon well we used to hike i mean she
and i wouldn't hug
i would hike every day but a lot of
times she would come with my dog
it's like i've got to get back to that
canyon spot
just uh in fact in i mean there's a lot
of things i got to get back to
but one of the overwhelming driving
forces was always my girls and
my family i mean um it's crazy when this
happened because i was
at the zenith of my career
and then professionally said and
personally alison and i just bought like
the house for our dreams we've been
waiting 10 years to buy
we're literally an escrow when it
happened so i'm in the icu
she flies in with her best friend jensen
thank you jensen and to my best friends
from
from high school and my best friend from
la they all fly to kind of take care of
her
and she's fielding for calls from our
mortgage broker about
are we pulling out of this deal and i
was sort of
the church i learned because i was not
in my quite right mind i was sort of
wicked about these fever dreams going
keep the house i want the house i
couldn't drink there was this pool and
i'm dreaming of rehabbing in that pool
right so wake up she's like we've got to
make decisions like keep the house
keep the house my financial advisor was
in for and he drove in he's like
don't keep the house all right
we thought we had enough money for it
he's unforeseen medical expenses because
that's all i'm gonna say
you and thank god thank god we didn't
keep the house because obviously my
career kind of came to a massive halt
and i'm working a little bit but surely
not the level i was before
so my income is certainly up in
it's incredible i mean i i can't even
imagine
and by the way do you have strokes in
any strokes in the family history
uh my grandmother had one but that was
an old age kind of stroke
right but mine was this weird thing like
you didn't realize that young people
have strokes our friend rob benedict you
know rob bennett
robbed my dear friend from supernatural
right are you open for his band
yeah i love him he's such a great guy
he's the best so rob had a stroke and um
which they never really came to the
bottom of what but he also had a carotid
artery dissection his was on the left
side
which the left side affects your speech
more
so he's actually been really
instrumental in helping me sort of come
to this and
guiding my way